die ausbildung anlage in tschechien
bietet gewaltige
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten mit chemischen
kampfstoffen das heißt wir sind also
hier in dieser ausbildung anlage in der
lage mit chemischen kampfstoffen das
heißt mit realen kampfstoffen zu
arbeiten und unsere leute
dementsprechend auszubilden
ich fühle mich sehr gut weil wir
kompetente ausbildung ab 41 lässig aber
sonderserien nicht nur drucken training
sondern richtig zwischen und im
hafengebiet arbeiten
österreichische soldaten sind es im
ausland gerade im pc bereich sehr
gefragt aus zwei jahre kranken erstens
die gute ausbildung die wir in
österreich erfahren
und zweitens natürlich die
einsatzerfahrung die im bereich der
arbeitsjahre eth vorhanden ist
die motivation der hier eingesetzten
rekruten und konnte den ist sehr hoch
einzuschätzen
es ist eines der highlights der
ausbildung die sie im laufe ihrer htc
ausbildung erfahren ist sicherlich diese
ausbildung mit kampfstoffen hier in
entscheiden